deadheads descended on santa clara
california just a few miles from where
their beloved dam was born for the start
of the bands a short farewell tour on
saturday and sunday fans packed the
parking lots outside of Levi's Stadium
and wearing tie-dye steal your face
t-shirts it was plenty for sale we have
snowboards we have skateboards we have
shoes from sandals to tennis shoes with
our new guitars alvarez guitars so
there's a long list of licensees 20-plus
years after Jerry Garcia died Grateful
Dead merchandise is still a cash cow not
just for the band but also for
rhinoentertainment the division of
warner music they're very into doing
licensing deals and they want the
trademarks to be out there but yes they
want to be compensated for it as do we
Rhino entertainment 8 to 10-year deal
with the Grateful Dead in 2006 giving
them control of the band's trademarks
website studio albums and live
recordings
even in 2006 the concept of a 360 deal
was just a brand new deal so this is one
of the original ones it was really one
where Rhino saw the full breadth of what
made the Grateful Dead The Grateful Dead
for a long time the band made most of
it's money off concerts Grateful Dead
controlled ticket sales merchandise for
a while it ran its own label it's not
that they had a hostile relationship
with the record industry there was
always kind of a friction between the
record companies saying we we need you
two to become consummate studio
musicians and put out good records and
their attitude was no no we want to be
consummate musicians and that means
plenty live but everything changed in
1995 after Jerry Garcia died the band
stopped touring and it's surviving
members were less interested in running
the day-to-day business of the Grateful
Dead there was probably a sense that
they needed the kind of outside help
that a company like rhino could bring to
bear that trying to do that in house
probably would have taxed them too
severely with rhinos help the dead has
sold 35 million elbows counting runner
hopes that will be enough to ensure
another lucrative deal with the band
it's been a great run and I'm confident
that we're gonna work with them for many
many years to come to do that the band
needs to grow its fanbase and that may
be the most valuable part of these
concerts I want everybody just kind of
it wow this music is really really good
and the business will follow from them
there's a reason they were the number
one touring band for ten years it wasn't
just the circus that surrounded them it
was because these are great musicians
playing great songs
ladies